solarworld hat er jetzt dieses carlos
castaña kastanien spanien in die eier
geworfen
serviceleute und herzlich willkommen zu
einem blogs entlang immer wieder
erkennen es wieder auf einem kanal noch
heute könnte es voll und durch berlin
wir können es einfach mal schauen was
die welt passiert so leute sind wir in
den screens am ufer übrigen muss jetzt
mal zu den besten pizza ladens hier
mittlerweile gibt ja wie die pizza essen
mit
ich wollte das natural etwa 50.000 tage
bart merkels machtwort jetzt gerade aus
dem osten und süden
heute stehen wir heute den den selbst
gedruckten die gdg schild pullover trägt
wofür steht sie schreibt in die
kommentare werden wir das war ist das
wichtig wir müssen weiter von homo- und
die asics dafür müssen aber es müssen
import gemüse gut aus dem christmas pack
sorry dafür dass er zumindest aber
richtig selbst wenn leute sich die stadt
nicht gewohnt ist die ganzen und gucken
einen an
dabei erzählt man von irgendwas richtig
richtig leute sonst war da nicht was wir
unter sozialer oder sogar richtig
ihr könnt es war eine recht
hier richtig lecker tono natürlich und
margherita und dazu baba orange oder was
ist richtig geil ausprobieren
zusammen
dies sei
16 euro
reykjavik
kastanien geworfen aber mein bein
getroffen meine beine die pizza gegessen
die war von 11 so deute eine ganz
wichtige sache noch falls ihr das jetzt
seht wird jetzt juckt oder anderen
schreibt auf jeden fall mal in die
kommentare
ob wir heute abend zum public viewing
auf der fanmeile mit millionen menschen
und ist nicht übertrieben sco möglich
200 millionen
die lok machen sollen aber ein halbzeit
doch nur einem eine million eine million
zeige ich es gar nicht also in die
kommentare schreiben
über die hälfte meiner abonnenten meine
abonnenten machen
die kommentare bewusst sehen wollte
o
das war es heute mit dem besten spieler
aller zeiten gefallen hat dann das einen
daumen nach oben da wie gesagt in die
kommentare schreiben ob wir den wm doch
noch haben wollt noch mal das für euch
es hat gar nicht ob er heute jetzt
wirklich noch da hingehen weil ich weiß
ihr sehen könnt ist alles bisschen
klatsch klatsch eingerechnet lag da ist
dieses geschäft ist wieder draußen
vielleicht alles